les onze blessés
combien de marseille
[Musique]
eh oui
voici ce que font vos animaux quand vous
êtes la voix 6 il faut quand vous n'êtes
pas là
la la la
cela soit bien sale connard pas là
[Musique]
comme des bêtes je m'appelle max et je
suis le chien le plus veinard de new
york grâce à elle traite mal ses
citoyens les abattoirs à ce soir jet à
plus tard mail
[Musique]
il
salut les amis j'en ai chargés oui j'ai
plein de projets je vais rester assis là
et attendre que cathy rentrer à la
maison
oh elle me manque tellement voilà dix
milliards c'est une grande nouvelle
max j'étais présent duke béton nouveau
petit frère
ouais ouais j'ai un gros problème
karti a ramené à psychopathe de la
fourrière j'ai même que blick dort par
terre comme un chien uk tentera de
cacher la vie il ne gaspille à l'urgence
moustache out est trop mignon toi
romaine
occupe toi tu épuré qui t'as fait ça
attendez tous a entendu papillon ta bio
publié aux papillons max a disparu
il faut leur trouver cathy va être mort
d'inquiétude on avait vraiment la belle
vie je m'en veux beaucoup
oui moi aussi je t'en veux beaucoup
on vous sort de taule mais à partir de
maintenant vous votez pour moi c'est moi
le boss
ok les gars vous n'avez rien vu ça
marche
pierre salvi je vais vous trouverez
votre année il faut qu'on prenne le
tunnel secret ouais le tunnel de la mort
qui tue on va retrouver notre chemin on
est les descendants du vignoble loup
[Musique]
on a un flair ancestrale ravi de vous
rencontrer et c'est pour ça qu'on sera
vite rentrer chez nous
c'est pas là bas qu'on habite la galère
comme des dettes soit bien sage léonard
quand il est bizarre totalement
irrationnel takavoir à la chienlit
d'achat il ya deux catégories de
personnes n'ont pas plus tard neil ceux
qui aiment les chats c'est impossible
d'aimer un chat autant qu'un chien sans
vouloir te vexer et ceux qui ont tout
faux si ça peut te faire plaisir par les
humains créateur de moi moche et méchant
comme des dettes
oui les tout premiers à wimby vouliez à
la la la la la
alors moi je prête ma voix à max tient
base duke un bain au mais c'est terrible
c'est un peu le petit chien cool on aime
bien la voir en potes un peu un peu
leader
ouais une minute tu vas peut-être un peu
loin là non tout va se compliquer le
jour où sa maîtresse va pas ramener un
chêne la fois ya qui s'appelle duke tout
va partir en vrille ça c'est mon appart
maintenant et mon petit link c'est un
gros chien
oui on les affuble ouais c'est vrai pb
zigouille a pas tenu il est pas tout il
ya s'impose en quoi il se rend pas
compte qu'il est né un peu lourdingue
quoi pour chaque mètre que j'ai tué si
j'avais reçu un dollars g - 1 dollars
voilà j'ai tué que celui là vous êtes
sans pitié rick mon personnage s'appelle
poupe avantage mois attention la seriat
passé d'accord il est très beau tout
petit mais il est complètement dingue
donc en fait c'est même pas un rôle de
composition pour moi oh je t'en prie tu
vas pas commencer chloé ce que je
voudrais c'est que tu m'aides map ça va
tu ton ami c'est une chatte elle est
obèse hockey et en tant qu'ami je vais
être franche avec toi je me fiche pas
mal de problèmes elles se sont très
supérieurs aux chiens ce qui est tout à
fait normal venant d'achat j'ai un plan
tout est détaillé les axes eu un super
rythme ça fuse ce sont des films qui
parlent absolument à tout le monde et de
petit message sous jacent tout ça je
suis très mignon pour les enfants je ne
sais pas bébel est un actionnaire est
drôle c'est impossible d'aimer un chat
autant qu'un chien sans vouloir te vexer
100% tout faux il y a deux catégories de
personnes est allée à plus tard mail
ceux qui aiment les chiens vous là qu'on
a besoin ne devient compagnon de l'homme
et ceux qui ont tout faux que si elle
est bizarre totalement irrationnel
accueillera à la chienlit d'achat at-il
pas les humains créateur de moi moche et
méchant comme des bêtes
à ce soir bridget pas [ __ ] mais vous
vous demandez parfois quoi penser aux
animaux or elle me manque tellement
j'ai oublié mon portable moi elle me
manque tellement de quoi il parle
ravi de vous rencontrer et ce qu'ils
font quand vous n'êtes pas là tu sais
quoi je dis j'ai un plan tout est
détaillé les actions il lui manque un
boulon à la peluche la maxe je te
présente si duke et il va être ton frère
chloé j'ai un gros problème tu ton lundi
et en tant qu'ami je vais être franche
avec toi je me fiche pas mal de
problèmes ça c'est mon appart maintenant
et mon petit li fuyu que tu a piqué une
crise que tu vas voir ça cathy elle va
flipper graf
mais c'est qu'un vase un vase duke un
vase oh mais c'est terrible il va pas
rester longtemps
et max vieux alors on se promène murray
qui t'a fait sa rentrée
knox a disparu
[Musique]
moi regarde pas rose regarde moi dont je
vais vous sortir de taule
ok les gars vous avez rien dû à ça
marche je vais retrouver ma famille
alors comment tu te sens grand-père
paralysé
tu conduis comme un cochon
je suis un héros tromper mais stylée
obstiné comme des bêtes soient bien sage
léonard
oh oui vous f1 qui hyundai qui on est on
est les frères inc pierre abandonné par
le propriétaire est bien décidé à se
venger
sorte de club sauf qu'on morts y compris
les gens et aux menées nous non sans
façon mascotte vous empester la
domestication appeler une truffe
vous avez choisi votre camp vous allez
finir en dogme alors attendez un peu
nouchi un domestique dans l'ariège
domestique vous avez tout faux on est
comme vous les gars on est les humains
ouais ouais grave c'est vrai nous faut
pas nous parler des bipèdes hachée par
les audois on a tous les deux brûler nos
colis est carrément web brûlé réduit on
sent et on a tué nos maîtres ou une
minute tu as peut-être un peu loin là
non
anne riff ouais on les affuble benzouia
pas tenir chaque mètre que j'ai tué si
j'avais reçu un dollar à 2 ouf j'aurai
un dollar velin vu que j'ai tué que
celui un derrick brooks andouille et se
sont tous enfuis
[Musique]
je souffre so2 boulette we wept tout où
on tient ton copain avantage mois
attention là s'est rien passé d'accord
pièce
[Musique]
chloé je me fiche pas vraie beauté
problème
[Musique]